we've got a voicemail number it is two
one nine two David P the Eggman wanted a
David Pakman show calendar left a signal
for his wife and it failed miserably
take a listen to this hi Dave
I took my wife's desktop computer I put
it open to um David Pakman / calendar I
left it like that so I know she found it
waited like maybe a couple hours later I
told her honey I really need a calendar
for next year for my office five minutes
later slips out like some pita or Humane
Society calendar
she has like here you go honey that's it
I just wanted to tell you I tried Dave
okay so alright have a good you know
whatever holiday yeah valiant effort
from the egg man but for everybody else
you can get yourself a calendar at david
pakman.com slash calendar 18 and you can
get the calendar for free if you sign up
for membership david pakman.com slash
membership for more info about that you
can also get just a calendar if you want
all the information at david pakman.com
slash calendar 18 we've got a great
bonus show for you today
and also make sure to check out our
latest patreon target at patreon.com
slash david pakman show we will speak to
you either tomorrow or on the bonus show
right now if you remember